the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video all
right my friends in this video i will be
discussing something else that was said
during george rr martin's interview with
house of the dragon's co-creator ryan
condell
now as you all know we have seen a lot
of different updates ever since hbo
started developing house of the dragon
we have known ryan condell and miguel
sapochnick our house of the dragon
showrunners we also know who a lot of
the actors are because not only did hbo
announce it but we have also seen some
of them filming scenes on set we know
the first season will release in the
following year and if you've seen my
last video you even know we will see 17
dragons in this new show like i said we
have found out a lot of information
about house of the dragon however out of
all that information i believe what i am
about to discuss in this video is by far
the most significant
now i am sure there will be some of you
who don't agree with me but all i ask is
that you at least hear me out if you're
even slightly interested in house of the
dragon as a game of thrones successor
show you should listen to the whole
video if you're someone who still thinks
house of the dragon will suck you should
definitely listen to the whole video
because i believe this information gives
us a glimpse into its future like a lot
of you every once in a while i will find
myself worried about this new show there
are some days where i will bet my life
that house of the dragon will be a great
show then there are other days where i
think uh oh i'm not so sure hbo is
handling this the right way they might
mess things up again i have those same
feelings like everyone else well i now
feel a whole lot better about the
success of this show now that i have
heard what i am about to show you i
think a lot of us will agree that the
most successful shows have amazing
writers now there are always exceptions
but if you think back on your favorite
shows i would bet almost all of them had
great writing in most of their seasons
now think about how game of thrones
actually unfolded even if you loved
every single season you still know there
are millions of fans who hated what
happened with the show once it no longer
followed the author's original writing
hbo needs those millions of fans if they
ever won house of the dragon to reach
the same heights as game of thrones most
fans would agree that the first four
seasons of game of thrones were some of
the best seasons in the history of
television not only was that when dan
and dave were following the song of ice
and fire novels but that was also when
george r martin was helping them write
some of the episodes some of you might
not know this if you're a new fan but he
did write some of the greatest episodes
the show had to offer he actually wrote
one episode for each of the first four
seasons now after season four ended
george rr martin was no longer writing
on game of thrones the very last episode
he wrote was the lion in the rose which
was joffrey's wedding after this he
stopped writing for the show and he even
stopped watching game of thrones for a
while he said he left game of thrones
because he needed all of his focus on
finishing the wins of winter now i never
actually believed that was the only
reason because he never stopped working
on everything else he had in development
it was as if game of thrones was
literally the only thing he stopped
working on for some reason ever since he
walked away from game of thrones after
season 4 he had worked on a dozen
different things although the winds of
winter was never finished this has me
worried about how active he would be
with house of the dragon now i know it
says he is one of the show's co-creators
but it also said that for game of
thrones and we all now know he only
wrote a handful of episodes before he
walked away for good so just because
george rr martin's name is slapped on
house of the dragon does not actually
mean he will be sitting in the writer's
room every season helping guide them
along the way well i am no longer as
worried as i once was
we now have an official confirmation
that george rr martin did write the very
first episode of house of the dragon
and i went home and i remember i told i
told my wife that's crazy meeting uh
george wants to hire me for this thing
he's going to tell hbo about it and i
said because at this point i was a
deeply cynical screenwriter as we all
should be and i said i'm never going to
hear from anybody in this ever again
and
i remember the next day hb uh not hbo my
agents called and said
did you have a meeting with
george rr martin yesterday
what happened hbo business affairs just
called and they made it off it was it
was this crazy thing it happened the
next day and then we were off to the
races and and you know went out to meet
george and br we broke the pilot
together the back of it and and uh you
know kind of this was three years ago
now but uh the rest the rest is uh
is history in the writing as a matter of
fact him and ryan condell house of the
dragon's other creator actually sat down
and wrote the episode together now this
has me very excited because it has been
so many years since george rr martin has
written an episode for game of thrones
knowing that he is actually helping them
with this show is better than any of the
other updates i have seen for house of
the dragon this might even be a big
reason why hbo decided to order a full
season without even seeing a pilot
episode first this actually doesn't
happen very often especially with a show
that has a budget of this size when all
of hbo's other shows were getting made
the first thing they would do is order a
pilot episode then if they liked what
they saw they would order a full season
well hbo did not do that with house of
the dragon they decided to order the
whole first season instead and i would
bet it's because george rr martin helped
write the first episode something he
didn't even do with game of thrones now
i'm not done yet this is not the only
good news regarding the show's writing
i'm sure some of you have been wondering
if ryan condole is the right fit for
house of the dragon some of you might be
wondering if he even knows anything
about a song of ice and fire well that
answer is yes it seems like he knows a
lot more than the game of thrones
writers did david and dan were fans of a
song of ice and fire whereas it sounds
like ryan is a student of a song of ice
and fire there is a very big difference
i think ryan also has one big advantage
over david and dan house of the dragon
already has an ending george rr martin
laid out all the groundwork for house of
the dragons ending many years ago now i
really want you to hear what else ryan
said during the interview because i
think it says a lot about who he is as a
writer you know we had done an uh
a round of development
if you go back
when it was clear that the game of
thrones was ending that dave and dan
wanted to end it after seven seasons or
something
hbo started looking to develop other
other shows
and um
the two that i pitched were dancing with
a dragon which became
uh house of dragon and uh
the dunkin egg thing
but there were a number of other shows
that were developed at that time
most of them put together by writers
that hbo hired
uh
who had never read my books
and who i guess had watched the show and
they were doing and when we were getting
into this i didn't want that anymore i
obviously none of those shows ultimately
got on the air i thought you know i want
people if they're going to be working in
my world i want them to actually have
read my books and i like ryan's work and
i knew he knew the world he had read the
books so
once again in that bar at the four
seasons uh yeah where it all uh started
there
how tell me about how you guys met a
little bit because i think our audience
would actually really enjoy this i'm a
super fan and i i found the books
at this point over 20 years ago
and uh i loved them i was a huge uh
tolkien fan lord of the rings just that
you know worshipped at the at the at the
altar of it uh the movies were coming
out and i had i just reread them and i
was in this kind of fantasy mode and i
was like what else is out there and a
friend had recommended hey if you love
tolkien you should really check this out
because it's it's really the only it's
the it's the it's the only thing since
tolkien that really got me up out of my
seat fantasy wise i've liked other
fantasies i've enjoyed things uh there's
some great classic books out there but
nothing to me held the candle to to
tolkien but this did and it was of
course the first book game of thrones
and i read it and i just i fell all the
way in i was all in like you know i i
couldn't believe how good it was i i
read all three uh there were three books
at the time storm swords that just had
just been published and i just devoured
them and then went back and devoured
them again and i and it just it became
my favorite thing so and this happened
at a time where i was learning to to
write myself uh i was very interested in
screenwriting i'd written a couple of
scripts i was starting to try to make a
a career of this i was in my early 20s
and um you know cut to a number of years
later i'm not i've now broken in i still
love these books i'm a huge fan of the
television show i'm watching it all i
tried to get at some point i tried to
get my agents to get me a staff writer
job on the show and they were like they
don't have staff writers it's just the
two of them write the whole show
so um i respected him so much and
actually learned so much from him as a
writer because i i mean i credit even
though the
the books are prose books george started
as a dramatic writer a screenwriter in
television the books are written in this
commentary dave you've read them they're
written in this incredibly cinematic way
with hooks at the end of chapters
there's dialogue i mean it's written you
could very easily just put slug lines
into those books and create scenes out
of them it's not a novelistic style of
writing so i learned a lot about
character and storytelling and
atmosphere and theme and all these you
know
literary tools like you know
foreshadowing and how to you know how to
write prophecy compelling prophecy that
doesn't seem you know uh uh dinky or
foregone conclusion all these things
that that i i still use today that i
learned from those books so it was just
really exciting for me to be able to
meet george and then we and then we hit
it off and then you know on down the
road we go you know some you know five
six seven years later turned into uh a
job offer which still i mean as still it
still
blows my mind that i'm that i'm sitting
here doing this show
now maybe it's only me but it really
does sound like ryan will be focusing on
the things that many fans saw as david
and dan's weaknesses i mean they
basically admitted to leaving certain
aspects out of the show i'm sure some of
you remember the interview where david
benioff said themes are for 8th grade
book reports this angered a lot of fans
and for good reason i'm sure some of you
also remember what david and dan said
after game of thrones ended they said
they didn't want to focus on any of the
fantasy elements as much because they
wanted a wider fan base i don't see
these as their only weaknesses either i
know i'm not the only one who is angry
with the way david and dan handled the
fantasy elements the magic and even the
prophecies in the show this greatly
affected the faceless men the lord of
light the night king azor ahai the
valonqar the dragon has three heads and
so many other amazing aspects of a song
of ice and fire after season 4 of game
of thrones when david and dan were no
longer following the books they
basically abandoned all of that so what
does that mean for house of the dragon
well if you listen to what ryan kondel
said during his interview with george rr
martin not only does it sound like he is
interested in those things but it also
sounds like they will be a focus of his
as well i don't think ryan will leave
any of those aspects out of house of the
dragon this is why i think he is a
better writer than david and dan and
this is why i think he is a student of a
song of ice and fire whereas david and
dan were only fans it doesn't matter how
amazing your show looks and sounds if
the writing sucks
game of thrones season 8 was incredible
in every single way except for the
writing and that's why many fans see
that final season as a failure
i believe this is our most significant
update regarding house of the dragon
because i think this will have a greater
effect on the show over any other area
we have seen so far we unfortunately had
to learn that the hard way with game of
thrones i honestly do not see that
happening with house of the dragon after
hearing this interview i feel like the
show is now in good hands and let us not
forget ryan condell isn't the only
showrunner miguel sapochnick is there as
well who we all know as the director
from some of game of thrones greatest
episodes like hardhome battle of the
bastards and the winds of winter i don't
know about all of you but i feel a lot
better knowing george rr martin was a
writer for the first episode and knowing
someone like ryan is there to manage all
of the other episodes after that
i just hope he doesn't let us down
now if you're someone who is waiting for
my next episode of game of thrones
season 9 i will be releasing that video
next there was so much new house of the
dragon information i had to get out some
of these videos first now i want to
finish my version of season 9 so i can
start working on a lot of other things i
hope i will see all of you back here for
that video as always thank you all so
much for watching this one have a great
day everyone i will see you soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you